hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
the importance of laboratory diagnostics
in the fight
against tuberculosis i'm susie valdez of
labrutz and i will be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by
lab roots and sponsored by bd for more
information about our sponsor please
visit their site at bd.com
so let's get started i want to remind
everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation
to do so simply type the into the ask a
question box
and click the send button if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
report that problem by clicking on the
ask question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd now like to introduce our presenter
dr daniela
maria terrillo clinical
microbiologist and the head of the
emerging
bacterial pathogen research unit at san
rafael scientific institute in milan
for a complete biography of our
presenter please visit the biography
tab at the right side of your screen
daniella welcome you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much susie and good day
good morning good afternoon good evening
wherever you are
and i am very pleased to discuss with
you the relevance of the laboratory
for the diagnosis of tuberculosis i'm
very pleased to discuss today today is
the word tb day
the day in which all stakeholder
comes together to celebrate
progresses and to um
really fight for what is still needed
to win the battle against one of the
worst epidemic
that we always had with us tuberculosis
this is the disclosure slide and the
opinion
or whatever i'm going to say is really
up to me and that that doesn't reflect
the view of the sponsors and the agenda
of today will be because it's the tv day
to go through the global burden of tb
to discuss the different programs to
stop tb
worldwide the role of diagnosis to
eliminate
tb that is actual goal especially
in low tv settings
such as the one i am living in
italy gaps in the diagnostic pathways
and i will conclude with the next the
question
for research and the way forward
the global tb epidemic we have
10 million of pb estimated
cases out of them we were able to
diagnose
a little more than 7 million that
leave us a gap of 3 million of cases
that go undetected in the community
and they are fueling the epidemic they
are spreading
the disease among the diagnosed
in the predicted cases we
have approximately 500
000 mdr or refunds in resistant cases
all those less than a half have been
diagnosed
and less than that put on treatment
so we are still generating 1.4 million
of tb deaths per year this is a huge
number when we compare with the data of
covet 19
you need to consider that every single
day
4 000 people die of tuberculosis
and 27 000 get
infected with tuberculosis those are
huge numbers that have been going
on and on and on with
sorry i was just if we look at the
global incidents by sex
and country that really depends on the
settings
but globally we their highest
burden is among adult
men these figures really changes with
their epidemics in the different
countries
we and it really depends on
who in the country is hit by the disease
but in general women are less affected
although we have 32 percent
that are women and the rest 12 percent
our children children are difficult to
be diagnosed
so the disease gets in children
both unreported
or over diagnosed and this is really
linked to our gut
in being able to make a proper diagnosis
of tuberculosis in children
if we look at the estimated tb incidence
rate
in 2019
we still see that the highest incidence
is seen in sub-saharan africa
where tb is full tv epidemic
is fueled by the hiv epidemic
instead if we look at where
the mystery case are
in very large number we can see
that of these three million of
missed case that are fueling the
epidemic and if we do not find them
we cannot stop the transmission
we have five countries that
are accounting for the majority
of the missed cases so
really implementing the capacity to
perform diagnosis
in those countries will be able to
change the figures
of the whole world
the other major problem of the tb
epidemic is
multi-drug resistant tuberculosis
multi-drug resistant tuberculosis is
defined
as the form of tuberculosis that is
resistant
to a refampicin and isolite
we do have good diagnostic tools
to speed up the detection of
tuberculosis but
of of drug resistant tuberculosis
but of course in order to do that
you need to have people presenting to
the laboratory
and to be able to perform the diagnosis
when we look at the number where do we
have the huge
problem of tuberculosis is in
india china and in the country of the
former soviet union
including russia in nature in the
european union
the the countries with the highest
incidence of mdr remains the baltic
countries india china and russia
by themselves they have more than 50
percent
of all the rifampicin resistance
or mdl tb cases
but the problem may be getting bigger
there are modeling that are based
on the projection of what is done today
to diagnose a to handle
multi-drug-resistant tuberculosis that
show that in
almost all high-risk settings and
here we do have four different examples
taking india philippines russia
and south africa all high burden
settings for tuberculosis and also mdr
tuberculosis
continuing the business as usual
we can project that the percent
of multi-drug resistant tuberculosis
among
all incident cases of tuberculosis
will increase to more than 12 percent in
india
almost 9 in the philippines
almost 32 percent in russia
and that between in seven
and around seven percent in south africa
by
2040. those are huge numbers
and they could really
compared our effort to combat
the disease to fight the disease
since 1994
the who has developed a global strategy
to try to combat
and control tuberculosis in all settings
they started with the dos strategy
and the dot strategy was a pretty good
strategy
that could put the
the government commitment as the first
option why is the government commitment
so important if you don't have
the money if you don't have the
government
that is committed to fight the disease
that allow those two to have available
the resources
to fight the disease really
nothing can be done and then
the strategy was case detection
through passive case finding so people's
self
self reporting to the laboratory
and people would have been diagnosed
to sputum smear microscopy
so only at that time the laboratory
was considered central but with a very
simple
technology all more than 100 years older
technology
and then all the people that
were diagnosed as a sputum positive
they should have been treated with
a anti-tb drug with the short course of
the anti-tb drug
and making sure that the drugs were
always available
in the system so nobody had to stop
the therapy because of talk out
in addition it was the beginning of the
establishment
of a strong monitoring system
able to perform a program supervision
and evaluation it was the beginning of
the surveillance
program of tuberculosis one of the best
surveillance that was established at the
who
of course that gave some results but was
not enough
so in order the mdio came out
and it was a huge need
to implement the high quality dots
not only the direct observed therapy
that is what the dot means
but the strategy as a whole and it
became clear
that two factors were really
um going to be addressed
in order to achieve the results the tv
hiv epidemic and the mdr tb
and in order to do that there was no
other choice than
understanding that the all health system
needed to be strengthened and everybody
should be engaged in the fight against
tb
public and private partnership were at
the beginning
and in some countries they are still the
way
to go the private sector is still
very important and the private
laboratory sector
needs to be upgraded at the public level
in order to make sure that they provide
the same quality that is provided by the
laboratory
that are under the mtp system and then
the empowering of people with tb and the
community
and enable and promoting research
without research we wouldn't be able to
have the tools
that we do have today to make the
diagnosis of tb
and the one that we hope to have in the
future
and then in 2016 we moved
to the end tv strategy the ntb
strategy is really changing the pace
and we are now working around
an integrated patient center tb
care and prevention so the patient
is at the center of our attention and we
need to have
policies and supportive system
no more pyramidal vertical
system but more integrated
system that are able in terms of the
laboratory
even to share platform to share
instrument
and then a big focus
in on research and innovation
these are the three action that
should make us avail make us
in the condition to reach the target
of 2035 are we there yet
i i'm not sure we are completely on
track
we are losing ground but if we apply
those strategy we should be better
suited to reach the goal then the who
is coming with current is is coming with
guidelines
i didn't go to all the publication that
we are available
but finally we do have what we call
consolidated guidelines we do have
consolidated
guidelines in all the area
including the laboratory area
and why is so important to have
consolidated guidelines
because guidelines are coming regularly
and are updated every year but
in order for people to be able to look
at them
and really interpret it in the correct
way
you need to have one one guide
that gives you everything and everything
is handy otherwise you may come up with
contradictory messages
as in the field of laboratory in which
one guideline
was recommending the interpretation of
some
tests in a way and then other guidelines
may have recommended a slightly
different interpretation
that could be confusing for the people
in the field
but moreover more of all
we do have the very new one on screening
in order to detect more
cases we need to change our capacity to
perform
screening we cannot only refer
to people that are self referring
for diagnosis because they are
symptomatic
we know from surveys that people that
are transmitting the disease are
non-symptomatic and they are still in
the community
with this who operational
handbook on screening the who
is readily coming with a roadmap
on how to screen what to use
how to monitor how to implement
the and which group should be the
priority target
for tuberculosis in order to increase
the case detection
do we pay at all to the disease in terms
of the economic impact
yes tuberculosis is making
everybody poor family
they are suffering devastating cost
and we need to stop the cost
of tuberculosis for the patients
coming with more support
including economical support
people don't only die for tuberculosis
they died with their family for the
poverty
that is increased by the tuberculosis
another important player in the field is
the stockdb
partnership the stocktv partnership
is the house of more than 1 000
organization among governmental
development agencies technical agencies
and
ngos and there is the general
the mother stopped a stockdb partnership
in geneva hosted by the u.n
but there are also very important
national partnerships
that are born to help people to fight
tb and we have different example
because the partnership are readily
driven
by the need of the country and here you
have two
different examples in india
that partnership works with the
community to improve
tb care especially for the marginalized
and the vulnerable population
they improve the capacity to bring these
people to the diagnostic center to make
sure that those people are aware
of the process and the fact that they
needed to be diagnosed if they are
they have any symptoms in the philippine
the tuberculosis really brings together
the serious society
and gives voice to the private sector
and to the patients in italy
the stock tv needs to fill the
the the the the gap that we have
with the engagement of the institution
and the government government commitment
government is not perceiving the
diseases a major issue
is still pers is perceiving the disease
like as
something that is not
an important health problem in our
country
so we need to keep the government
aware of the problem
in the same way through the time
the role of patients association became
a huge and important factor
even for the diagnostic field
patients are supporting and advising
they can share their experience they can
make the
changes happening they can
provide the patient perspective
and this is an important factor for the
development
of new diagnostic we think that now
more than ever patient patient
should be an important player in
deciding what are the priority the
preferences
of in the new diagnostic field
the stopdb partnership as working groups
as you probably know the working group
are the research arm of the partnership
the partnership is a working group on
new tb vaccines
on new drugs and in new diagnostic
and i am the co-chair together with
martin rutfeld as find
of the new diagnostic working group we
do have a vision
that is the high quality of diagnosis of
tb
and drug resistance should be available
for all people in all settings not
only simple tests but as sophisticated
as sensitive and specific as we could be
in implementing the technology
into simple devices
as a mission we foster the development
and the scouting and
evaluation of the new diagnostic we try
to be the coordinator the communicator
and the advocacy platform
for all stakeholders involved
in the field we do have a
vision for what is needed we need to
have
triage test to be used at the point of
care
like we are talking now of c
reactive protein for hiv
co-infected people simple tests
tested with um low specificity but
high sensitivity to rule
out the disease and then
to really channel into the diagnostic
pathway
the people that need a better screening
then we need to have tv confirmatory
tests
that with rapid and the integrated dst
for pleated for the critical drug
to drive regimen decision
you know that we are pushing for
decentralization of
mdr treatment and for that
we need to be test for drug resistance
at the same level and then we still need
to have
comprehensive dst and i will go back to
this point
when we will discuss the new definition
of the xdr tb
what we have learned from the covet 19
lesson
if there is something that we did learn
is that we needed to be ambitious
because with covet
19 both in term of vaccine
or in term of diagnostic we have seen
the impossible become reality and
in very short time what was the
difference
with the tv world the amount of money
that were invested by the whole world
in the field and that we need
to continue
but the covet 19 has taught us a lesson
it was probably a good lesson but we
also need
to think what is going to be um
the result of what i call a collision
of pandemics what you see in this graph
is the trend in monthly notification of
people with tb
in four ibird and countries
january to june 2020
so you see that the notification in
india as an online system for
notification
so the system is really ready to pick up
the notification and what you see
is that there was a huge drop
in the notification in all the settings
when india was going just going
up increasing the missing cases
then a huge drop in the reporting
and that is going to have
a huge effect and what you see on the
right
graph here is that in india
both the public sector and the private
sector were equally affected
and although the numbers are going
up we don't know what will be the
results
but modeling analysis shows
a possible increase of annual tb debt
to the number that we had eight years
ago
and the stopdb partnership estimates
that additional 6 million of tb
cases will be notified
between 2020 and 2025
and out of them a substantial number
will be children that are the most
affected by the disease
so what can we expect we have seen a
really different scenario by this
collision of the two pandemic
we have seen the fact that everybody is
wearing a mask
mask is protecting
from spreading tuberculosis but mask
is also
an anna say what is good about covid
and the mask is that muscular
stigmatizing the tb patients in the past
now that we everybody is wearing a mask
i've been out with a mask
since march last year
so it's more than one year now we don't
feel
we feel that nothing is wrong in wearing
the mask
all the time sure we are hoping to drop
that
but still we can we can live with that
and there are also a lot of diagnostic
improvement in the mask there are
studies that have shown that particular
strip
could be inserted in the mask and could
be used
as a material to capture both
coved and tb basili so in the future
we could also consider to use the mask
as a device as a diagnostic device
to concentrate bacteria for example for
for children that are not able to
expectorate
then social distancing social distancing
is probably stopped the transmission
of tuberculosis in the community but
on the other side we had
um we we already
have locked the people in their houses
and most people live in crowded houses
and there was a decreased access to care
due to logistics due to the lockdown
and other issue and in addition
our laboratory where we converted
and the staff was either reconverted as
well to covet work
but was also thick so we end up
being understaffed in the laboratory and
i can show you the experience
of laboratory and high burden settings
where the only level three laboratories
were the tb laboratory
is and they were shut down for the tb
work and reconverted to the coveted work
so we don't know yet the magnitude
of the toll that we will be paying to
this
epidemic
certainly what we know is this
we used to have tuberculosis as the most
the biggest single agent killer
in the world certainly 2020
has changed the figure because covet
around the world became the biggest
killer
but if we look at the global fund
eligible
countries that are those that you see in
orange here
you see that they covet reported
tb debts are less
than a quarter of the total
death of tuberculosis so in those
countries
tuberculosis is still the major killer
so keep it in mind
now we need to approach
the pathways of tuberculosis disease
progression
and this is changing over time with more
understanding of
the of the disease what we know
now more is that we don't talk anymore
about latent infection
and active disease we know that we are
moving gradually from infection
to a active disease
that is non-symptomatic for a while
or can also go to
cycle of disease that go up and down
in which people are completely
asymptomatic
not produce they don't have bacilli
and they um move up and down
to those phases becoming infectious
only when they move out
from the uh the infectious
phase that is an important
reflection on the diagnostic that needs
to be
developed and used for detecting
more cases of tb here you see
a different way to say to to show
the diff the same different
conceptualization of the disease in
which you have the people that are
uninfected
people that are just infected and those
are eyeglass positive
they cannot spread the disease and then
you have
people that are they have active
tuberculosis
this is the old and classic
conceptualization of the disease
diagnostic for latent infection
diagnostic for active disease
now we do have different phases
we know that people become infected
some of them will clear the disease but
they will still remain
eyeglass positive then
some of them will cannot control the
infection
so they will move to the incipient
infection most likely they are not going
to transmit
because they are not basilary but they
are they have already in their body
changes that should be captured
in order to make another an early
diagnosis
of this group of people that is fooling
the progression
and then is fooling the group of people
that will become
actively infected and will spread
the disease there is a group in
in the middle that is the group of
subclinical
disease those are the people that are
totally fine
clinically speaking but they have
already some
chest x-ray of abnormality and they do
spread the disease
although they are palsy symptomatic they
could be basically producing
and they could really spread the disease
if we care about stopping
quickly the epidemic and the
transmission
we need to target both the people with
active disease
and the people with the subclinical
incipient and
latin form of disease if we look at the
cascade of care
from the laboratory point of view we see
that
we miss the initial diagnosis
here and only if we do a successful
diagnosis
we can move these people to treatment
without a delay and then once the
treatment is
is initiated we need to keep the people
in the system
in order to make sure that the treatment
is appropriate and the role of tb
diagnosis is fundamental and is
different as is shown in this
publication
in the different settings how can we
increase the role of diagnosis in
india the role the major gap
is on the private setting if the private
setting
doesn't use the high quality
diagnostic the recommended who
diagnostic
algorithm then we are going to miss
a lot of cases if we implement
algorithm in which the in which
we do have the private sector fully
engaged
we will be able to decrease the
diagnostic delay
of four to six months decreasing
transmission
if we go to kenya in kenya
it's the problem is the hiv cascade
delay that is fueling is is the major
gap
that needs to be addressed so diagnosis
of hiv providing
art and providing an
isoniazid preventive therapy will only
affect the mortality of the tb
patients and will have an impact
with a reduction of almost 56 percent in
incidence
and 77 in mortality
in the future in moldova
what can affect the
the number of can really have an impact
in the system
is instead the implementation of fast
drug susceptibility testing so
implementing
and almost the point of
uh point and labor the peripheral
laboratory proper
drug susceptibility testing in moldova
will have the biggest effect
in the mortality of the tb patients
and we can see that the diagnostic
gap in in the tb care cascade
are always in the diag in the capacity
to bring
the people into the laboratory
and to properly utilize the laboratory
the diagnostic
tools as recommended consider that we
now
have a much larger menu
of laboratory diagnostics and
not all of them are appropriate called
settings
so right now what is missing
and what should be developed by who and
partner
is a guide to select the proper
diagnostic
for each settings
there is an evolution of diagnostic for
tb
we started from microscopy and culture
we are moving to genomic and universal
dst
consider that when we are talking about
universal dst we are really talking
about molecular dst
for few drugs we need to bring this
molecular dst for few drugs
to a more comprehensive
capacity to examine the bacterial
genomes and to predict
the sensitivity to the drugs that are
used
for the first line treatment and for the
second line
treatment and then in addition
we need to increase the acknowledged gap
on bacterial health biomarker
and to move them closer to the patients
with technology that uh
um platform free
let me move to one simple example the
who
has newly defined the xdl tv
so now the xdbrtb is a the form of tb
caused by mtb strains
that fulfill the definition of mdr soil
with emphasis in isoniazid resistant
and are also resistant to any
fluoroquinolones
and at least one additional group a drug
what is the problem group a drugs
are pedagolina and linesolid in addition
to fluoroquinolones
for those we do have phenotypic and
genotypic tests
there are advantages for phenotypic
engine and disadvantages for both
phenotypic
and genotypic definitely the genotypic
is faster
but in order to be applied you need to
know the determinant
of drug resistance right now
for bedaquiline and lead
we are probably not able to report
xdrtv correctly but not
only in eyebird and and law resources
setting
really nowhere because we don't
have very strong
and reliable phenotypic tests
for bedaquiline and the netherlands
we still we are still discussing the
critical
concentration we may risk
an over-reporting or an under-reporting
and definitely that will take a time
that is considered too long
to start the treatment of the patient in
the periphery
and for genotypic tests again we are in
the same situation
because the determinant of drug
resistant to the diagoline
and the nasolid are really not
as clear as the determinant and the
molecular determinants for other drugs
let me add more we do have so few
strains that are resistant to linearly
that even the positive predictive value
or phenotypic test
will be still too low to be interpreted
with some
accuracy so we
did a survey in europe to check
which laboratory you were really able to
report
and we find out that even in the
european
laboratory network there was really
not a large capacity to
test for the new group
a drugs
the other major need is the alignment of
the enthalpization for phenotypic dst
this is just to show that we have
critical breakpoint oh my god
defined in the u.s defined
by the who and defined by
europe the so by the ucas that is the
european
committee we cannot continue to go on
with that
we need to standardize and align so the
same patient that is diagnosed with
mdr uh with um with a critical
concentration in the u.s
keep being sensitive of resistance if
he's diagnosed
in europe on a second strain full genome
sequencing has a lot of potential
it emerged as a technology that could
really revolutionize the way we see tv
as conventional application with fast
detection of phenotypic drug resistance
allows us to investigate
the genetic diversity philogenesis
to determine the lineage consider that
the more data we are collecting
the more we think that even in
antibiotic
resistance could we could see a lineage
effect
so knowing the lineage will allow us
to refine them and interpret
more correctly the q the the
resistance test when is performed by
phenotypic
testing and there's also a lot of public
health application
in epidemiology and surveillance ecdc
has just established the genome
sequencing
as the the way to perform surveillance
for cross-border clustering of mdr
strains and then there are
unconventional applications that will
allow
us to study the ethereal resistance and
the mixed infection
the virulence factor and to study
the new drug resistant associated
mutation
and the possible cross resistance
there is what is the challenge the
challenge is to move
out from genome sequencing and move
closer to the patient's encounter in
order to do that
what you need to establish at the first
action
is to have a mutation catalog of
all what we know and we consider
associated to drug resistance
only if we know the mutation
we are able to correctly interpret
the genomic data that
we can provide through a virgin on
sequencing
or next generation targeted sequencing
and in order to have the tool
available we really needed to combine
that effect coming from all over the
world
and to examine to
a common pipeline and have a group of
experts
revising the data and really establish
based on solid algorithm the association
between mutation and drug resistance and
so far we know that
some rotation are really confident
markers of some of drug resistant for
some drugs
but there are also mutations that we
should ignore because they are not
associated to drug resistance and
without
having this solid background we may
make huge mistake in interpretation
now let's move very quickly
to the subclinical incipient and latin
tb
the reservoir of people developing
active tb
the current tb infection diagnostic tool
are all based on the the uh
indirect test that are only able to
demonstrate
either in vivo or in vitro that there is
a host reactivity
toward the m tuberculosis antigen
now the who is now coming with
recommendation on ruling in a tbi
and screening different groups and they
recommend
both tst or idols
to screen high risk
groups and in order to offer them
preventive therapy
we do have some new generation of tbi
tb infection tests we do have some
new sf6 based skin
tests that will be um coming out
in that one of them is already available
in russia
and in former soviet union countries
there are others that are under
evaluation and validation so they will
be available
and they will have the advantage of the
eyeglass
not cross reacting with bcg and other
mycobacteria
with the um advantage of the tst
so to be very cheap and easy to be
performed
and then we have a lot of next
generation hydras that are coming in the
market
but what is the problem the problem is
that
this new i guess will really decrease
our capacity to so it will decr
will decrease the time to result
the cost but really they will not
have a better positive predictive value
compared to the current hydra and in
fact
what is missing is a good test for the
incipient tv
and the super clinical tb
we are still very far from that all what
we have right now
is a positive predictive value that is
too low
to be used for that in
reality we are
the researcher has been producing
a lot of new and very interesting
results
so we now have a clear idea of the
biomarkers
that that all the fact that the
biomarkers
are really suitable tests for
predicting progression
of the infection for predicting
subclinical disease but unfortunately
when we look at the performance of those
biomarkers
they are only able to predict
in a very short time
the progression to the disease so they
are only able to predict
enough a time frame of three to six
months and this is what we have today so
if we are
only able to predict disease progression
with
between three to six months we should be
we should be testing the people too
often
and become unpractical so there was a
recent
uh um a very interesting publication
by in landsat respiratory medicine
that really focused on that they were
looking at
17 different signatures that may come
in the market in the near future
and they were coming up saying that no
one of them
is really meeting the target
of the technical product profile
established for those tests
by the who what is
interesting then to see is that most of
the signature
converge in the target so
continuing the research is very
likely that we will be able
to get a suitable test in the future
what are the priority research question
for the
the future what is the impact of the
subclinical in cpn tb
in the transmission dynamics we need to
have a test that to detect
these status in order to find out
what will be the performance of the
horse biomarker for the different status
of disease
do we need new tests to stop
therapy and declare cure we continue
that
the therapy for the same amount of time
for everybody but
we know that someone could stop earlier
and someone could stop later and the
culture
is not the right proxy universal dst
how to cope with capacity and logistics
all over
and then tools based on either genotypic
dst and phenotypic dst
for any new drug entry in the market
we are tired to see the drugs before
we have the suitable test and now
this has been one very difficult year
but in this very difficult year the
society that i'm
honored to represent the european
society of mycobacteriology
has been working a lot in the
partnership with becton dickinson
to provide training and to provide
webinars that could be of interest
for the majority of the people involved
in the fight against tb so
we are going to after three different
webinars at the end of may
beginning of june on simple best
practice for a successful tb diagnostic
non-tubercular mycobacteria for
diagnosis to treatment
how to integrate the diagnostic offers
into a suitable algorithm in different
settings
speakers will be excellent and
i really invite all of you to follow the
european society of mycobacteriology
website
to be aware of the date and the time
and with that i'm reaching my conclusion
despite
progresses and gradual decrees of global
incidents worldwide
tb hits hard still hitting in many
countries in the world
the larger menu of diagnostic available
today
needs to be supported by a guidance on
how to perform
choices that are proper for each
settings
universal dst concept will be
met by application with user-friendly
genomic
test current tests to ntb
will be missed we need to develop
more to work more we need a test for
incipient tb
with a sensitivity that is acceptable
for at least up to six months
persistent tests will be needed to apply
the test and treat strategy to eliminate
the infection the current agra are not
going to solve the problem
in high burden settings what the true
impact of covet 19
i don't know that will only become clear
in the next future
and i need to thank you for your
patience
i'm open to all your questions i also
would like to thank
my collaborator the people affected with
db
and their family all the people that are
involved
in the fight against tb from all
aspects from science peace to companies
to society members and every one of you
thank you very much and now i am
happy to tell you that to remind you
that today
is the 2021 tb day
let's hope that next year we'll meet in
person
thank you very much for your patience
and thank you daniela for that
informative presentation
and we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on that
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so let's get started it looks like
daniella we already have
some great questions coming in from our
audience members
our first question how can we find out
more about the educational series by esm
you should visit our website the
european society of microbacteriology
website
and you will find in a in
more or less two weeks the exact date
and time we also have on youtube
the older series of webinar
that you are more than welcome to to
watch
and you'll find the link on the website
as well as you are more than welcome to
look
for the date of the meeting that will be
at the end of june beginning of july we
will have
an online meeting with almost
no fee for registration
thank you so much our next question is
from an audience member
who is located in silmar california
and she says i'm located here in sylmar
california a historically significant
location in early 20th century of tb
treatment and research and i've also
worked with dr froman
in 1979 is there a clear link
to tb infection by smoking as there is a
connection
with hiv yes
there is a link between smoking
and tb infection and progression
of disease and also outcome
and the inca is
is coming clear from a lot of
publication
that shows how the deterioration of the
lung
promoted by the smoking by the the heavy
smoker
is uh really um is promoting
the progression of tb from infection to
disease with form of disease
that could be more difficult to treat
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience members for these
great questions
coming in our next question how would
you recover
the backless trap in a children's face
mask
to work as a collection instrument in
diagnostic
this is still a prototype that i have
seen
and there there is a special material
that is
uh it's buffered that while
you are exhaling because we are now
wearing the mask all day long
when we are outside and enough work
so you keep exhaling and you can exhale
the bacteria the bacteria get
trapped and then you can
dissolve the bacteria
and get them certainly you cannot use a
smear microscopy but you can have
different technologies to uh detect
the bacteria and that are trapped
on these tweets thank you so much
daniella and we have time for a couple
more questions
is tbt cell response
still a valid tool to support tb
programs from
who from w.h.o
yes sure uh well uh
you know them well any sport
was never completely or any sport
is endorsed is still
available on the global fund menu
but so it can be purchased
to the global drug
the gds definitely those tests
as well as the skin skin test
the tst and the new skin test
will go to our vision by the who
those are very imperfect
tests with the problem to
to to have no capacity to predict
who is going to progress into the
disease
so for the double the who only focus
on the high risk category and whoever
as a positive test will need to be
treated
and in fact when we talk about children
we we think that their recommendations
are that small children should be
treated if they are
contact of a case anyway
definitely other tests with a higher
predictive value for progression
or needed daniella we have time for one
more question
and this is a good one is there any
vaccine
against tb well
you know that there is a they all the
bcg
is still in use and is an important
vaccine for children really is able to
prevent tb meningitis in children
as well as a serious form of tb
in in small children doesn't protect
orders to from tubercula
perform pulmonary tuberculosis later on
there are several trials with several
promising candidates that are ongoing
but i must say that the one of the
factor of
covet 19 is that all the trials
have been either stopped or delayed
so the covet 19 will be will have a huge
impact on research and will only
also have a huge economic impact because
what was the cost of a trial has been
increased
because of the stop caused by kovid
of about 10 to 20 percent
with no money leaving the the the
scientist without money to complete the
trials in some cases
but yes they allow promising candidates
daniella i want to thank you again for
your time today and for your important
research
and i'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor bd
for underwriting today's educational
webcast and before we go i want to also
thank our audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and thank you
very much susie i will be happy to
answer the question if people would like
to email me
that's not a problem at all thank you so
much again daniella
and you can view this webinar on demand
and lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay that's
all for now
take care everyone and stay safe until
next time bye bye
bye